The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHAEL SHORT: Want
to give a quick review
so that we can launch into some
more technical stuff today.
We started talking about this
reaction for boron neutron
capture therapy was the
focus of today's lecture.
And I want to get this
one up on the board
since I'm going to move
to different slides later.
We had boron 10
captures a neutron
and becomes lithium 7, helium 4.
There's a gamma ray.
And there's going to be
some q value, or energy
either released or consumed,
in this case, released
in the form of the kinetic
energy of the recoil products
as well as the gamma ray energy.
So let's also give a quick
review of the Q equation
since I think we
covered that last week.
If you remember, if you have a
general system of, let's say,
a small initial nucleus i firing
into a larger nucleus capital
I, after the reaction, off
comes some small final nucleus
and some large final nucleus.
If I were to draw
these arrows to scale,
the little one would
probably be moving faster.
Then we can figure out how
much mass and kinetic energy
each of these nuclei are by
just conserving everything.
So we can write, let's
say, the mass of nucleus i,
c squared plus the
kinetic energy of i
plus the mass of
big I c squared.
Plus the kinetic energy of big I
has to equal the mass of little
f c squared plus the
kinetic energy of little f
plus the mass of big F c
squared plus its kinetic energy.
And what this tells us is
if the total amount of mass,
or the total kinetic
energy change,
they've got to exchange
energy kind of equally.
So we can write the difference
in mass or energy by just,
let's say, taking
all of the mass terms
and putting them on one side.
So we can say that--
let's just say everything here
is multiplied by c squared.
We have M i plus M I minus
M little f minus M big F
has got to equal the sum of
the final kinetic energies
minus the initial ones, which
we also call this Q value.
And so by getting the
difference in the masses
or the kinetic
energies at the end,
you can figure out
whether this reaction
is exothermic or endothermic.
If you remember, we said
if Q is greater than 0,
it's exothermic.
If Q is less than
zero, it's endothermic.
In a nuclear reaction
like a chemical reaction,
you've got to input extra
energy into the system
beyond just the rest
masses of the particles
to make an endothermic
reaction happen.
For example, since we found
out that this BNCT reaction is
endothermic, you can
make it go the other way,
but you have to impart
kinetic energy to one
or both of those nuclei to
overcome the Q value that--
let's see-- yeah, to overcome
the Q value that you'd get.
And I want to put up a
couple of other terms just
to quickly review.
We started looking at
the table of nuclides.
We learned how to read it
specifically to find things
like excess mass
and binding energy,
the definitions for which I want
to leave up here on the board.
So we had the excess mass,
which, again, doesn't
have a physical significance.
It's the difference between
the actual mass of a nucleotide
and the integer
approximation of its mass
just from the number of
protons and neutrons,
and the binding energy.
Since some of you asked
for a nucleus uniquely
defined by its total mass number
a and number of protons z.
So let's say this is
a functional quantity
because you can have any
nucleus with a certain number
of protons and a certain
number of protons plus neutrons
would be the sum--
let's see-- the sum of
its individual nucleons
minus its actual
mass, which also
is a function of z
and a, or its proton
number and its total
atomic mass number.
So let's leave these
things up on the board
while we move into
some new stuff.
So back to where
we were on Tuesday.
We wanted to figure
out, well, how do we
calculate this Q value?
You can do it any of three ways.
You can use the masses,
like we have over here.
So the masses in amu, or atomic
mass units, times c squared
gives you the Q value in MeV.
Or the difference
in kinetic energies
gives you the Q value in MeV,
although you don't usually
just know these off
the bat, especially
for the final products.
Or you can use the
binding energies.
Because the binding
energy is directly related
to the mass additively, you can
substitute in binding energies
here and you'll
get the same thing.
And so if we have the
table of nuclides,
you can either use
the atomic mass
of any nucleus or
its binding energy
and just look it up directly.
The thing with the
fewest steps is just
to use the binding energies
because those are already
given in MeV or keV.
And then it's just an
addition subtraction problem.
If you use the
masses, don't forget
to multiply by c squared.
And remember our
conversion formula,
which should not be rounded,
which is this right here.
Again, 931.49, not 931,
not even 931.5, or else
you're off by 10
kiloelectron volts.
And so then the
question is, all right,
let's try to calculate the
Q value from this reaction.
I have the individual energies
and kinetic energies up here.
But just so we have
a worked out example,
let's actually do this.
So the Q value of
this reaction should
be the binding energy of lithium
7 plus the binding energy of--
what do we have-- helium 4 minus
the binding energy of boron 10
minus the binding
energy of a neutron.
Now first of all, the easy one.
What's the binding
energy of a low neutron?
Let's call it out.
0, yeah.
A lone nucleon is not bound
to anything, so that's easy.
That's 0.
And we can just use
the table of nuclides
to look up the other three.
Luckily I've got
it live over here.
So let's just punch these in.
We'll have boron 10.
And our binding energy
right here is 64.75 MeV.
Let's look up helium 4.
Good.
That's showing up on the screen.
I think I'll make it bigger
so it's easier for everyone
to see.
The binding energy
is 28.296 MeV.
And notice everything's
already in MeV,
so this is nice and
easy to deal with.
And lithium 7.
39.245 plus minus minus 0 MeV.
Let's see.
Actually, I think my sines for
exo and endo are backwards.
Let me fix that right
now because the idea is
if you release energy--
there we go.
Sorry about that.
No, wait a minute.
Let's calculate this
out, figure what we get.
And again, I can't do
six digits in my head,
but I will do it as
fast as I can here.
245 plus 28.296 minus 0.75.
Ah, indeed.
2.79 MeV.
I had it right the first time.
So good.
Shouldn't second guess myself.
Cool.
So now we know the total
Q value of this reaction.
And I'll bring the
reaction back up here.
We also know, which you
can find from measurements,
that the gamma ray comes off
with an energy of 0.48 MeV,
leaving--
let's see how much--
leaving 2.13 MeV for the
sum of the kinetic energies
of the lithium and
the helium nucleus.
So let's say Tli 7
plus t for helium.
Now the question
is how did I get
to those numbers for the split
between the kinetic energies
of those two?
Anyone have any idea?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Related to their mass?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
So it's definitely related
to their relative masses.
More specifically, we
have this conservation
of energy equation,
but we've still
got two variables
and one equation.
We need a second equation.
That certainly does
relate the mass.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Conservation momentum.
MICHAEL SHORT: You can
relate their momentum.
So we can say that if this
initial kinetic energy of boron
and of the neutron was
approximately 0, then
it's like these two
nuclei, lithium and helium,
were kind of standing
still and all of a sudden
moved off in opposite
directions, which
means they've got to have
equal and opposite momenta.
So let's say the absolute value
of the momentum of lithium
has got to equal
the absolute value
of the momentum of helium.
This is our second
equation, where
we'll use the first one
to figure out what are
the relative kinetic energies.
And so we're going to use a
quick trick to say if momentum
equals mass times
velocity, we can also
say it equals the
kinetic energy, which
is 1/2 mv squared, and then
multiply by things in order
to make it mv.
So we can multiply by 2.
Let's make a little
bit of space here.
If we take the kinetic energy,
multiply by 2, multiply by m,
and take the square
root, we have t.
Let's see, that
would give us 2 m
squared v squared inside
the square root gives us mv.
So now we can take
these expressions
and we can say that the root
2 mass lithium, t lithium,
equals root 2 mass
helium t helium.
And they both have
a square root of 2.
We can square both
sides of both equations.
And we end up with mass
of lithium t lithium
equals mass of helium t helium.
Now we take this equation,
rearrange it a little bit.
Let's just call that Q to
keep things in variable space.
And we can say that t helium
equals Q minus t lithium.
We can take this t
helium, stick it in here.
We end up with m
lithium t lithium
equals the mass of helium
times Q minus t lithium.
There's a missing h right there.
There we go.
And then from here--
oh good.
We've got some blank
space right here.
Let's see.
So we'd have-- I'll
do out all the steps--
equals mass of helium times
Q minus mass of helium times
t lithium.
And we're solving for t lithium,
so we can put this term over
on the other side.
So let's say t lithium
times the mass of lithium
plus the mass of helium equals
Q times the mass of helium.
Then we can just
divide both sides
by the sum of those masses
Those two terms
cancel, and we're
left with the expression for
the kinetic energy of lithium,
which is the mass of helium
over the sum of the masses
times the total Q value.
Looks like the two of
those might actually
be backwards, huh?
Because the lithium
one should be smaller.
I'll correct that for the
notes when I put them up online
because this ratio should
be smaller than 0.5 Q.
But at any rate, this is
how you actually get them.
And I want to
point out something
a little flash forward
to some of the decay
that you're going to be looking
at in terms of nuclear decays.
Let's talk for a second
about alpha decay.
In alpha decay, you have a
low nucleus sitting around.
And then all of a sudden it
emits a helium nucleus as well
as a recoil nucleus.
And one of the questions
that came up a lot last year
is why isn't the Q
value of an alpha decay
reaction-- let's just write one
up on the board, possibly one
that you'll be dealing
with very soon, hands on.
Uranium 235 can spontaneously
go to a helium nucleus.
That's 92 plus
looks like 90 to 31.
What comes before uranium?
I think that is thorium,
although I wouldn't-- yeah,
I think that's thorium.
And the idea here
is that there is
some Q value associated with
the kinetic energy of both
of these.
But it's not the
alpha kinetic energy
because the thorium nucleus
would have to take away
some of that kinetic energy.
And I want to show you
this on the diagrams.
So let's look at U 235.
And we can see that it has an
alpha decay to thorium 231.
Awesome.
Got the symbol right.
And it has a decay
energy of 4.679 MeV.
Let's take a look
at the diagram,
which actually lists all of the
possible alpha decay energies,
of which there are many.
Had to zoom out a
little bit there.
Yeah?
Anyone have a question?
OK.
So notice that the difference
in energy levels is 4.676 MeV.
And if we look at the
highest energy alpha ray,
it's less than that.
And that's because just
like we showed up here,
the thorium nucleus
has to take away
some of that kinetic energy
to conserve both energy
and momentum.
So this is a question that came
up quite a few times last year,
and I want to make sure you guys
don't get tripped up like this.
So again, I think I've
said it every single day,
and I'll say it
again because it's
the next day, is make sure
to conserve mass energy
and momentum.
That's the whole
theme of this class.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do
you get that value
for [INAUDIBLE]
mega electron volts?
MICHAEL SHORT: Should
have been 2.79 minus-- oh,
did I do a little
mental math mistake?
That should be-- oh.
Yeah, no.
A little dyslexia thing.
3, 1.
Yeah.
There we go.
Thank you.
Cool.
OK.
Is everyone clear on how
to calculate Q values
from nuclear reactions using
either kinetic energies, which
you won't typically know, or
masses or binding energies,
which you can look up directly
from the table of nuclides?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what did you do
down there in the bottom right
corner of the chalkboard?
MICHAEL SHORT: Of this one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
So I took this expression
right here, which
is to say the Q
value has got to be
the sum of the kinetic
energies of the lithium
and helium nuclei, rearranged
it thusly to isolate--
ah, there we go--
yep, to isolate the
helium kinetic energy,
and then substituted
that expression in here
to get this one right there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
So this way, we have--
in this case, we had,
let's say, two variables
and three unknowns.
But because we have this
equation relating them,
we're left down with two
variables, two unknowns,
and we can actually
solve this thing.
Yep.
Yeah, good question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The energy of the
gamma, is that just a known?
Like the .48 MeV?
MICHAEL SHORT: That's
something either
I tell you or you would
measure, let's say.
That's just for completeness
to say all right,
this reaction actually
gives off a gamma,
and I want to give the right
value for the kinetic energies.
And we'll get into what
gamma transitions are allowed
and then how you measure them
in the next couple of weeks,
actually.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So do we refer to Q as
the Q you calculated up there,
or that 2.31?
MICHAEL SHORT: They're
the same one, actually.
AUDIENCE: The 2.7
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh, I see.
That's a good point.
So this wouldn't
really be Q, would it?
But it is the sum of
the kinetic energies.
This is like Q minus
the gamma ray energy.
Let me stick that in there.
L, i.
Yep.
Yeah.
Good point.
OK.
Any other questions
before I move on?
We're going to get into
a universal formula
to predict in a so-so way what
the binding energy of any given
nucleus will be and start
looking at stability trends
so you can predict, just
from the number of protons
and the number of neutrons,
how stable a nucleus will
be with a few exceptions,
which we will go over.
And this is what's referred
to as the semi-empirical mass
formula.
So I'm going to
erase some stuff.
Has everyone got the notes on
this bottom board right here?
OK.
Let me know when you're
ready, and let's see.
Yeah.
I want to make sure I
move at your guys' pace.
Let's say going to have a graph
of binding energy per nucleon
on versus nucleons.
Well, anyway, I'll
leave that up there
and I'll do the work on
this board right here.
So let's say we wanted to
figure out a weighted graph
or to predict the binding
energy per nucleon.
So I have this
binding energy term
over a, where a is the
total number of nucleons,
as a function of the
number of nucleons--
in a generalized way.
Not accounting for magic numbers
or anything else that we'll
get into pretty soon.
And I don't like the
term magic numbers,
but that is the parlance
that's used in this field
so I'm going to stick with it.
Let's try and think about
if you imagine the nucleus
as a kind of drop
of liquid-- and one
of the other words for the
semi-empirical mass formula
is called the liquid drop
formula or the liquid drop
model.
It assumes that the
nucleus takes the shape
roughly of a liquid
drop, and you can kind of
treat some of the energy
terms accordingly.
This is why I have all the
different colors of chalk out
for this.
Makes it a little
visually easier to see.
So let's start writing
a general expression
for the binding energy
as a function of a and z,
and start thinking
about what sort of terms
would add to or
decrease the stability
of a given liquid drop nucleus,
where all the nucleons are just
kind of there in some sort of
floating, crazy, coulombic,
strong nuclear force soup.
First of all, as
you add nucleons
to a given nucleus,
what tends to happen
to the binding
energy, in general?
Without knowing anything else.
Assemble more nucleons, you
convert more mass to energy.
And you end up increasing
the binding energy.
So let's call this
the volume term.
As you increase the volume
of this liquid drop,
its total binding energies
start to increase.
So let's say there's
some term that's
going to be proportional to A,
the number of nucleons that's
in this liquid drop.
And we'll draw this.
Let's see if I can
do the trick right.
Yes.
I love doing that.
If we were to graph
binding energy per nucleon
as a function of number of
nucleotides for this term,
it would just be a flat line
because it's related to A.
And there's going to be
some constant, which we're
going to call the volume
constant, that says, well,
there's going to
be some relation
between the actual amount
of stability gained
and the number of nucleons.
We don't know what
it is yet, but what
we're really concerned
with is the functional
form of this thing.
It's proportional to A.
Next up, what also
happens to a liquid drop
as you increase its volume?
What other parameters
do you increase?
AUDIENCE: The surface area?
MICHAEL SHORT: Exactly.
The surface area.
The idea here is that
if this liquid drop
is made of all sorts
of different nucleons--
and let's pretend that they're
like atoms in a crystal
and they're all
binding to each other--
the ones on the outside aren't
bound to as many nucleons
as the ones on the inside.
And so the more nuclei
there are near the surface
as opposed to inside the
liquid droplets, say,
inside some little radius
where all it sees around
it are other nucleons, then
they're not quite as bound.
And how does the surface
area of a liquid drop
scale with its volume?
To what function or
to what exponent?
2/3.
I mean, let's take a quick
look at the volume of a sphere
is 4/3 pi r cubed.
And the surface area of a
sphere is 4 pi r squared.
So if you want to get
some expression for how
does area scale as
volume, I said cube,
then I wrote squared.
It's going to end up
looking like something times
r to the 2-- let's see.
Oh, yeah.
I'm sorry, that's not the
expression I want to write.
But the idea here is it's going
to scale with r to the 2/3.
So let's pick a
different color and say
we're going to have some surface
term times number of nucleons
to the 2/3.
And if we then adjust
this formula to also take
into account this
surface area term--
which is to say for
very small nuclei,
there's a lot of nucleotides
near the surface,
and as the nucleus
gets bigger and bigger,
more and more of them are in
the juicy center and don't know
they're near the surface--
we'd have some modification
that looks like that.
Now I'm going to erase the
stuff over here because I'm
running out of room.
Now these nucleons aren't just
untagged, anonymous nucleons.
They're either
protons or neutrons.
And what happens when you
try and cram a lot of protons
into one space?
AUDIENCE: They want
to repel each other.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
They want to repel each
other by coulombic forces.
And so every proton--
let's pick a different color
for the coulombic forces--
and that should be
a minus if I want
to stick with all the notation.
There's going to be some other
term to account for the fact
that the nuclei,
specifically the protons,
are trying to repel each other.
So in this case, it's going to
be proportional to, let's say,
the number of
protons that we have.
And every proton should
feel a repulsive force
from every other proton.
So let's say it's times
z times z minus 1,
so that every proton feels the
force of every other proton
except for itself.
And that's going to be
mediated by the total number
of nucleons.
So if there are more
neutrons in the way,
it won't be quite as bad.
And there's going
to be some other--
we'll call it a C for
the coulombic term--
and that will say that as
you make a bigger and bigger
nucleus, you start to get
more and more coulombic
repulsion trying
to rip it apart.
So if we were to then
modify the purple curve--
oops.
Trying to get it to go the same
as the nucleus gets bigger.
I want to make sure it's
really to scale-ish.
As the nuclei get
bigger and bigger,
it's going to be a
little less stable.
And already we're
starting to get
a curve that is getting close to
looking like the binding energy
curve from the reading.
But there are a couple
more terms to reckon with.
So let's pick a fourth color.
What other sort
of trends that you
notice in the reading about the
stability of different nuclei?
Let's say you were to take a
common nucleus like carbon-12.
It's got six protons
and six neutrons,
and it's exceptionally stable.
What about carbon 6?
A nucleus of just 6 protons?
Doesn't exist.
Exceptionally unstable.
What about carbon 24?
18 neutrons, six protons.
Sound stable or not?
Not at all.
So there's some sort of
asymmetry term going on.
When the number of
protons and neutrons
is roughly in balance,
especially for light nuclei,
the nucleus tends
to be more stable.
So we can write
some sort of term--
let's call it an
asymmetry term--
that relates to the
number of neutrons
minus the number of protons.
And in this case, for reasons
I'm not going to get into,
but are derived in a
reference in your reading,
there's a squared on it.
But suffice to say if the
number of neutrons and number
of protons are equal,
then the nucleus is
predicted to be pretty stable.
And this works out quite
well for light nuclei.
It starts to break down a
little bit for heavier nuclei.
And then divide by the number
of nuclei that there are.
I also see a missing
1/3 because let's say
this nucleus has a volume
that scales with roughly
the number of nucleons.
Then the distance of
that coulombic force
is going to be like A
to the 1/3 or the radius
of this nuclear drop.
So let's take the
asymmetry term.
That's going to give us a
further modification slightly
downward.
And finally, there's what's
called the pairing term.
What's the last
color I haven't used?
This pairing term delta.
And this is not a
smooth function.
It's a piecewise
function that depends on
whether you have an
odd or an even number
of each type of nucleon,
protons or neutrons.
And so what this
means, it's going
to add a little
bit of jaggedness
to the beginning of the curve
and equal out in the end
because this delta
term can be something
like plus, let's
call it an A pairing.
And it scales with the square
root of A, or minus, or 0,
depending on if the
nuclei are odd odd,
like odd number of protons,
odd number of neutrons,
even even, or odd even.
Now I know that the derivation
is a little hand wavy.
That's why we call
it semi-empirical.
We're taking each of
these additive terms
and saying it kind of comes
from a fairly OK, a little poor
approximation of the nucleus.
But what we end up
with is a formula
whose constants are fit, whose
terms, the actual variables,
are derived somewhat
from physical intuition.
These constants were then fit
later by some other folks,
and the references for
this are in the reading.
They're all in MeV, and this
gives you a binding energy
in MeV for a given nucleus.
Now it works some places and it
doesn't work in other places.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the lower
case a [INAUDIBLE]
no matter what the
nucleus looks like?
MICHAEL SHORT: That's right.
So this is the universal,
semi-empirical, usually works
formula for the binding
energy of a nucleus.
So the constants don't change
because the variables here
are z, [INAUDIBLE] a, and n.
And don't forget--
because you'll
need to remember this
on the homework--
that A equals z plus n.
So for example, if
you want to express
what is the most
stable nucleus, you
could take the derivative
of this formula with respect
to A or z.
And don't forget that you can
substitute this expression
into there.
That's giving you guys
a hint for the homework.
And let's look at what
this actually looks
like as far as theory
compared to experiment.
So the red points are
theoretical predictions.
The black points are
experimental predictions.
And all of the different
nuclei are shown here.
First of all, the curve looks
quite a bit like the one
that we just hand wavy made
on the board right here.
And second of all, there
aren't too many exceptions.
It's hard to see what
the exceptions are,
so it's a little
easier to draw them
in terms of relative error.
So you can see where
does this formula work
and where does this formula not?
So if you notice,
for the small nuclei,
approximating it
as a liquid drop
is not a very good
approximation because you
can't treat this
as a homogenized,
smeared liquid drop.
It's much more--
well, there's either
two or three nucleons, and
very few protons and neutrons
in each.
But then as you get to
larger and larger nuclei,
it starts to hit very
close with a few exceptions
that I want to
point out right now.
If you zoom in on that
part, you can actually
see that at certain neutron
numbers, or certain proton
numbers, there is an
exceptionally high stability
of a lot of those nuclei.
And that's as you
start to approach
these what's called
magic numbers,
or numbers of nucleons
which, say, fill all energy
levels at a certain level.
And again, it's not for
every nucleus as a function
of neutron number.
But even drawing an
envelope around this curve,
you can see that the
nuclei around 82,
around 50, around 28, are
a whole lot more stable
than the ones in between.
And this pattern kind of
repeats with larger and larger
periodicity.
And it kind of looks
like right here,
at the edge of our
knowledge of nuclei,
we haven't quite gotten
to the next peak yet.
This is something we're going to
talk about Friday on the quest
for super heavy
elements, or SHE's,
as you'll see in the reading.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the most stable
nuclei peaks were closest to 0.
MICHAEL SHORT: Closest to
0 is the closest agreement
between experiment and theory.
So the ones that are
exceptionally stable,
which are not predicted by
this very simple formula,
are up here at the peaks
of these magic numbers.
And actually, I want you to
take a look right here at some
of these very small nuclei.
Like helium 4 is probably
way up here somewhere, all
the way over on the right.
It's an exceptionally
stable nucleus
that is not very well
approximated by liquid drop
model because it's
got four nucleons.
They're all on the surface.
There's nothing on the inside
of a helium nucleus, let's say.
And then if you look at
stability trends in terms
of are the nuclei more stable
if they have odd numbers
or even numbers, you can
graph the two separately
and look at the number
of stable nuclei
that have an odd total mass
number or an even total mass
number.
And there's a few
things to note here.
One of them is the even
numbers tend to have
a lot more stable nuclei.
This is something I mentioned
on the second day of class.
If you look at the [INAUDIBLE]
table of nuclides--
let's go to their home page--
and just look at it
sort of in a color way.
The blue colors
are stable nuclei,
and you notice that
every other row of pixels
here has a whole lot
more stable ones.
And that's the same thing
that we're seeing right here,
is that there's a lot more even
nuclei that are more stable.
If I jump back to our
semi-empirical maths formula,
notice that this binding energy
goes up for even, even nuclei.
So when there's an
even number of protons
and an even number of neutrons,
the semi-empirical mass formula
does predict an
increase in stability,
which you can actually see
on the table of nuclides,
and on this sort
of stability trend.
And so let's look
a little closer
and see how many nuclei for each
proton number or each neutron
number are actually stable.
And we graphed the odd and
the even ones separately.
And what's important
to note here is one,
the odd is way
lower than the even.
There's usually either 2 1 or
0 stable nuclei at that number.
And what other sort of features
do you guys notice about this?
It's not smooth, first of all.
Where are those peaks?
Where do you tend to find
that most stable nuclei?
4?
Where do you tend
to find the least?
What about these two right here?
No stable nuclei at
these proton numbers.
And remember, proton number
uniquely defines an element.
Anyone know what
these two might be?
What sort of elements?
Look to the back of
the room if you want.
There's a periodic
table in the back wall.
And you can see, except
for the super heavy things
down at the bottom,
there's a couple
of elements that have
no stable isotopes.
These are technetium
and promethium, which
are relatively light isotopes--
I say relatively light compared
to things like uranium--
with no stable isotopes.
They're also fairly far away
from these so-called magic
numbers or other regions,
where you tend to have a spike
in the number of
stable nuclei due to--
well, things that
you'll learn in 22.02,
in terms of nuclear shell
occupancy and stability.
But you see the same thing when
you graph the neutron number.
You can see a couple
of sudden spikes
right here at 20,
28, 50, 82, and 126.
When everything gets really
stable, all of a sudden you've
got one last gasp
of a stable isotope
before you go off
into nowhere land.
So let's start looking at
relative stabilities of nuclei,
let's say, for a given mass
number or a given proton
number.
Anyone mind if I
cover this board
because you can't roll it up.
You all got the notes from here?
Cool.
That one has less to erase.
And I want to keep these
formulas up for our reference.
Let's say I pose this problem.
I want to find out, make sure I
solve the right one-- actually,
I'm going to check
my notes real quick--
that what is the-- for a given
A, or for a given mass number--
what is the most stable
number of protons?
for A, given A.
This is the question that
I like to answer here.
How would you
approach this question
using the semi-empirical
mass formula
that-- well, you can't see
here, so I will bring it
up back on the screen.
Here.
How would you find this out?
Well, let's say for
a given mass number
A, for a given poor
approximation of the total mass
of a nucleus, the more binding
energy it has, the more stable
it is.
Therefore, if you want to
find the minimum of a mass
for A and Z, given
a fixed A, that
will give you the
most stable nucleus
because it will tell
you which value of Z
gives you the
smallest m, or rather,
the most tightly
bound nucleus that
has the most binding energy.
So let's start writing this out.
First of all, we can use
one of the two equations
we already have up here, a
relation between the mass
and the binding energy.
The second one, well,
we have it right here.
So let's substitute in our
binding energy equation
and express it in terms of mass.
So let's say our mass of a
nucleus A and Z is equal to Z
times the mass of hydrogen
plus A minus Z times the mass
of a neutron minus
the binding energy
because in this case,
what I've done right here
is I've added mass to each side
of the equation, subtracted
binding energy from each
side of the equation,
and we can just take
negative that expression
and write it all out together.
So we have minus AVA plus A
surface A to the 2/3 plus AC z
times z minus 1
over A to the 1/3,
and plus AA symmetry and minus z
squared over A and minus delta.
So we've got one expression
for the total mass.
We've fixed the value
of A because we're
going to take some fixed--
we're going to choose
some fixed value of A.
Let's say A equals 93.
And that's the example that I've
kind of worked out in my head.
It so happens that niobium has a
stable isotope that a mass of A
equals 93.
And we just found out
in some of our research
that niobium doesn't stick
to chromium very well.
That's why I've got
it on the brain.
So this is what I was
thinking about this morning.
So for a fixed A
equals 93, we want
to find what is the most
stable A. How do we do that?
Anyone have an idea?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Differentiate?
MICHAEL SHORT: Differentiate.
Sure.
Let's take, we'll just say
the derivative of-- oh, no,
it is a partial
derivative because we
have two variables here.
Take the derivative
as a function of z,
set it equal to 0.
This will give us the
z number that gives us
the minimum mass for a
fixed A. So let's actually
do this right now.
So let's see.
This gives us mh.
And this term expanded
out is AMN minus ZMN.
So we have a minus MN.
I'm going to make one quick
correction right here.
I want to make sure
everything's in the same units.
All of these semi-empirical
mass terms are in MeV.
These right here are in
AMU, atomic mass units.
What do we have to add in
order to get these all in MeV?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the conversion factor.
MICHAEL SHORT:
Conversion factor, yeah.
Or in this case, we'll
just stick a C squared.
I'll make a little
bit of room so I can
stick the C squared in there.
C squared.
Now everything's in MeV.
We're all in the same units.
So let's say we
have mh minus mn.
These are in C squared.
And minus VC plus 2/3 AS times
A to the negative 1/3 plus--
I'm going to expand this out
to call it z squared minus z.
I'm also going to stick
in n equals A minus Z
so that this expands out
to A minus 2Z squared.
Is everyone with me here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't the A
terms, like the AVA and the AS,
stay at 2/3?
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh.
You're right.
I'm deriving with respect
to the wrong variable.
Thank you.
Yep.
So we want to do this
as a function of z.
So that term disappears.
That term disappears.
Thank you.
Let's work on these
ones right now.
So we have AC time z
squared over A to the 1/3.
So that will give us A plus
AC over A to the 1/3 times 2z.
And then we have--
let's see- minus AC
over A to the 1/3.
That's it, actually.
Oh, times plus 1, OK?
And then we have the A minus 2z.
So let's expand this out just so
we can see it all on the board.
So we have AA over A
times A minus 4z squared
plus 4 minus 4 AZ
plus 4z squared.
So let's take the derivative
with respect to z of that.
That term goes away.
That becomes 4A.
So we have plus AA
over A times 4A.
And there's a minus sign there.
And that becomes 8z.
So we have plus AA
symmetry over A times 8z.
And the delta term goes
away because there's
no z dependence.
And what we end up here is the
solution for what is the most
stable z as a function of A?
This is a linear equation.
There's only one
solution for it.
If we actually want to graph
this m as a function of A
and Z, we end up with what's
called a mass parabola, which
is to say you can graph the
binding energy per nucleon,
or the mass, or pretty much
similar things, of a nucleus,
of all nuclei with A
given as a function of z.
Think I can do this on the
remaining space right here.
So let's say 4A
equals 93 if this is Z
and this is m as a function
of A and Z. Let's actually
look at a concrete example.
So let's go live to
the chart of nuclides
and start looking at things
with a mass number of 93.
Looks like I clicked
a little too high.
There it is.
Let's see.
Moly 93 I was
looking at, and that
becomes niobium 93, which is the
stable isotope I was thinking.
So let's put niobium right here.
I haven't given an
actual scale to this
because I just want to show
you in sort of relative terms.
So let's say niobium
is the stable one.
So it's going to have the lowest
actual mass, even though it's
got an A number of 93.
If you look here on
the chart of nuclides,
you can see it could
have come from a couple
of different places,
either from zirconium 93
or from molybdenum 93.
And now is a good time
to start introducing
these different modes of decay
so you can figure out, well,
how would a nucleus decay to
get to the most stable place?
Let's say it came from
zirconium 93 and--
let's see, miobium has
a proton number of 41.
So if we go to
zirconium, it beta
decays to niobium 93 with
an energy of .091 MeV.
Very, very close.
So we'll draw it
slightly higher.
That's about 91 keV.
Zirconium 93 could have come
from the beta decay of yttrium
93 you can see right here.
So let's go up the mass
parabola and keep exploring.
And now we see that yttrium can
decay by beta decay with 3 MeV.
So if we put yttrium on this
graph, it would be way higher.
Yttrium itself could
have come from--
well, let's see, strontium
93 with the decay
energy of 4.1 MeV.
So let's put strontium here.
And I think 4 MEV would
be, like, off the chart.
But whatever.
That's the way we drew it.
Already we've got the
makings of a parabola.
And each one of these
can decay by beta decay,
or does decay by
beta decay, in order
to get to the most
stable nucleus.
So let's write the
nuclear reaction
for beta decay of one of these,
let's say, from zirconium
to niobium.
So we'd have 9340
zirconium spontaneously
goes to 9341 niobium
plus a beta and
plus an electron anti-neutrino.
That's the part I don't
expect you to know yet.
But that's the whole
energy conservation thing.
A little bit of a flash forward.
The beta decay energy
is not necessarily
the energy of the
electron that you
will measure because
some of that energy
is taken away by
the anti-neutrino.
But we'll get into how those
relate probably next week.
So let's now look on the
other side of the parabola
and confirm that the
semi-empirical mass
formula, which
predicts something
parabolic here and
here with respect to z,
actually checks out.
So let's back up to
niobium 93 and notice
that it could also have
come from electron capture
from molybdenum 93.
So let's put
molybdenum right here.
And it decays with
an energy of 0.4 MeV
into niobium, which let's
say it's around here.
Let's keep going
through the chain.
Anyone have any questions
so far while we keep going?
Cool.
Let's trace it
back up the chain.
Technetium 93 can
beget molybdenum 93
by electron capture with a
much higher energy, 3.201.
I'm going to extend our graph
because we need the space.
Technetium, another 3 MeV.
And let's go one more back.
Technetium can be made by
electron capture from rubidium
93 with an even
higher energy, which
means a higher difference
in mass between these two.
So so far-- let's see, what's
6 MeV for rubidium here?
It would be like there, I guess.
There's our mass parabola,
right from the data.
So I like doing this better
than just showing you a diagram
because you can actually
try it for yourself.
Pick a fixed A, change
A, and construct
the mass parabolas yourself.
Now the question is how could
these decay into niobium 93,
which is the stable isotope?
I have negative
one minutes left,
so I'm very quickly going
to tell you for large energy
changes, it can either be
positron decay or electron
capture.
And we'll go over what these
modes of decay are next week.
This can be, again, positron
or electron capture.
And for small amounts
of decay energy,
it can only be electron capture
because in order for positron
decay to happen, you have to
be able to create the positron.
And the positron plus
the extra electron
ejected to balance charge
has got to be 1.022 MeV,
or same thing as what's
known as two times the rest
mass of the electron.
I'm going to stop
there, and we'll
pick up with lots of examples
and questions tomorrow.
The last thing-- well, I'll
go over the next problem
set tomorrow.
I want to make sure
everyone's seen it
seven days before it's due.
And the best way to do that
is to show it on the board.